were some situations or some things that  you had to learn  kind of like the hard way in the music  game  was it some pub [ __ ] was it the label  [ __ ] man it was all the [ __ ] right it  was all the [ __ ] you know i'm saying not  reading contracts just  being just being blind to the money you  know saying money coming in and not  really taking care of business and the  business end up biting me in the ass a  few years later and i had to clean up  the business  and for the past couple years when  people thought i was gone i was cleaning  up the business  you know what i'm saying and that took  time to this day i'm still you know say  everything is back how i need to be  right right but it take time to really  like take some [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up and  fix it put all the pieces together by  yourself you know what i'm saying like  really like locked in on some  you know some pinky in the brain and  [ __ ] trying to figure out  you feel me so but i can't complain  either days